okay let's go to the eight one seven
area code caller from eight one seven
what's going on hey what's going on this
is Frank Bernie farofa I am a pre I'm
one of those three hundred guys that a
three hundred plus that became a new
member so maybe you talked about this
thing before okay but I'm just a quick
question I'm wondering about your own
credentials you were just talking about
college education you seem like a really
educated guy I didn't know if you're
just a self-starter or if you've got any
credentials yourself I actually did not
get passed sixth grade incredibly are
you serious isn't that insane
yeah that's pretty insane but that's
also I mean I'm glad that you're someone
that I'm an I'm an educator I just got
my masters in education I'm starting my
career right now so the fact that I can
have someone to point to and say hey you
know you can still succeed even if you
didn't get through sixth grade no I'm
just kidding I'm just having a good time
I actually I don't know man I'm kidding
around your reaction was so authentic
please clip that someone clip that out
of this live stream and we got it we
have to use that on social media no I I
have a under drive a bachelor's degree
in economics and communication and I
have a I have an MBA as well in
financial planning and economics okay
fantastic that'll make sense and I
figured you probably had done some
reading at some point you were you
probably had learned some stuff but I
was just curious thank you very much I
appreciate the call and thank you for
you by the way can you talk about how
membership is just the best thing ever
yeah it's fantastic I've been listening
to your podcast every day since I have
had access to them watch the videos when
I get the chance but a lot sometimes I'm
on the road and so commuting yeah it's
great to have the the excerpt the bonus
show is what you call it and and all the
extra contents fantastic so I appreciate
what you do I'm enjoying it appreciate
it and I'll send you that check I
mentioned if you would call in and say
this after I get off that would be great
alright big have a good night thanks yep
have a good one and speaking of
membership let me say thank you to
Abigail Moo nice also Chris Jones and
okay I think that's it and oh and Jerri
Hickel Jerri Hickel as well